le cher ami mon cher françois nous
sommes réunis en famille pourraient
conseil national qui est un peu
particulier c'est le premier conseil
national après les primaires et ce sera
le dernier conseil national avec la mère
des batailles juste avant les
présidentielles
c'est un conseil national un peu
particulier donc qui a des allures de
veillée d'armes qui a des allures même
d'un conseil de guerre parce qu'à
l'extérieur d'ici au delà de ces murs de
cette salle vous le savez bien et vous
les avez entendu les critiques les
balles fusent dans tous les sens
elles viennent bien sûr du système un
système qui a totalement ignoré françois
fillon pendant les primaires alors
évidemment ce système se déchaîne
mais ces tirs croisés viennent aussi
d'autres camps de plusieurs camps ces
tirs croisés d'abord viennent d'un quand
ils viennent de ces faux jumeaux c'est
faux jumeaux que sont la gauche et le
front national
faux jumeaux bien sûr parce que je ne
les confonds pas bien sûr que ce ne sont
pas les mêmes mais écouter les mots
qu'ils utilisent
écoutez leur expression ce sont les
mêmes les mêmes outrances les mêmes
caricatures brutalité violence pour un
peu françois fillon serait à la fois
responsable et dix plaies d'égypte de la
chute de rome est très prochainement de
l'apocalypse oui outrance ou transmet
aussi imposture ces gens là proclame
tous disent qu'ils veulent faire
campagne qu'ils agissent au nom du
peuple
en réalité leurs projets leurs campagnes
c'est sur le dos du peuple qu ils la
font
quel est le bilan social de la gauche
qu'est ce que la gauche a apporté aux
français les plus fragiles
si ce n'est plus d'un million de
chômeurs si c'était une pauvreté plus
grande encore qu'au début de ce
quinquennat si ce n'est
une chute du pouvoir d'achat un institut
love ce qui n'est pas marqué à droite
qui est plutôt marqué ailleurs nous a
révélé qu entre 2012 et 2016 les
français avaient perdu près de 600 euros
par an voilà le bilan social de la
gauche voilà cette gauche qui
méthodiquement à attaquer l'économie
c'est vincent peillon qui voulaient
arracher au déterminisme familiale les
enfants de l'école voilà cette gauche
qui a attaqué la famille bien sûr avec
la loi taubira qui l'a attaqué aussi
avec le coeur de la république
l'autorité de l'état l'autorité de la
loi
voilà le bilan de la gauche est celui du
front national marine le pen proclame
qu'elle est candidate du peuple de
france
ça signifie quoi de faire campagne pour
le peuple en trompant le peuple en
trompant le peuple en leur disant que
les français les plus faibles pourront
s'enrichir si la france quitte l'euro en
leur disant qu'on peut continuer à
travailler moins que tous les autres
peuples européens et qu'à ce moment là
on va s'en tirer grâce à cette molette à
cette facilité
voilà mesma la marine le pen sans doute
d'ailleurs que marine le pen voulait
s'adresser au peuple en est
en allant aux états unis en restant sur
le pas de la porte de l'histoire de la
trump tower
elle désirait tant se faire prendre en
photo sous les ors de cette tour
entouré du meuble de ses meubles et de
ce marbre de carrare voilà marine le pen
tous ceux et celles qui ont ces
campagnes régionales se souviennent
d'ailleurs que ces tirs croisés
nous les avons enduré de la gauche et de
la droite est d'ailleurs que constate
aujourd'hui que monsieur mélenchon dit
que monsieur philippe au fait du plagiat
et que d'ailleurs marine le pen
n'utilise pas seulement la voix les
expressions et les paroles de la gauche
elle reprend même jusqu'à l'emblème du
parti socialiste
jusqu'à la rose voilà c'est prouvé
marine le pen a besoin du système pour
prospérer
nous dénoncerons cette imposture ses
impostures voilà pour les faux jumeaux
meoli a aussi à côté de ce camp là il y
a aussi un autre camp celui des faux
amis famille avec emmanuel macron
emmanuel macron souriante l'ami de tout
le monde ni de droite ni de gauche
le candidat du ni pour ni contre bien au
contraire de tout à la fois mais en
réalité ce faux amis il est bien sûr
vis-à-vis du prison de république
il n a été le fossoyeur de sa
candidature alors qu'il en est le digne
et pur héritiers il est coresponsable
bien sûr du matraquage fiscal il a été
l'inspirateur de l'échec économique
il était le ministre de l'économie et
jusqu'au tignes de comportement ils
copient son modèle françois hollande
parce qu emmanuel macron c'est la
contradiction
hier contre l'ecosse 35 heures contre
liès f
aujourd'hui on sait plus où le flou
aussi lorsqu'il veut faire plus de 100
milliards d'euros de dépenses publiques
on lui dit banco chiche mon gars mais
comment tu fais il faut s'expliquer le
peuple de france a le droit à la vérité
donc vous voyez que ces camps est faux
amis c'est quand des vrais faux jumeaux
c'est le même quand c'est le camp des
bonimenteurs c'est le camp de tous ceux
qui depuis des années ont voulu parler à
la france en la segmentant en faisant du
marketing politique
en oubliant les convictions en oubliant
les colonne vertébrale des références en
face nous avons un candidat nous avons
françois fillon il est le candidat de la
vérité parce que j'ai une certitude qui
est en même temps une conviction que
vous partagez j'en suis sûr les français
en ont assez des fausses promesses et
des vrais renoncement et pour ce qui
nous concerne pour ce qui nous concerne
nous qui représentons la grande famille
politique de la droite les républicains
il y a aussi un message dans la victoire
de françois au primaire les français on
note aussi assez des petits renoncements
les français on entasse et d'une droite
qui trop souvent dès que la gauche
montait le temps et la gauche est en
train de monter le ton pour nous faire
oublier son bilan c'est tout juste
d'ailleurs s'il ne voudrais pas faire de
françois fillon l'ancien président de
république et bien rappelez vous une
seule chose les français de droite ont
en marre de cette droite qui passe son
temps à raser les murs de cette droite
qui passe son temps à baisser la tête
dès que la gauche hausse le ton ça n'est
pas notre identité politique
eh bien oui le cher ami aux côtés de
françois nous sommes pour la liberté la
liberté pour valoriser le travail
l'effort le mérite pour tous ceux qui
entreprennent en france
oui avec françois nous sommes pour
l'autorité l'autorité de l'état
l'autorité de la loi républicaine contre
les corporatismes syndicaux ou autres
contre le code le communautarisme
jamais nous n'accepterons la soumission
de la france ça n'est pas non plus notre
adn
nous voulons l'autorité de l'état parce
que la france est une nation qu'elle est
indivisible et bien sûr nous voulons
aussi une droite qui s'assume qui
assument des valeurs qu'ils assument des
convictions quand madame taubira disait
que son texte était un changement
civilisation et bien si vous vous êtes
attachés à notre civilisation
alors vous concevez aussi qu'il ne peut
pas y avoir de droit à l'enfant il n'y a
que des droits de l'enfant
alors bien sûr mes chers amis ne vous
effrayez pas c'est totalement normal que
nous soyons au centre des critiques et
c'est même rassurant que le système se
défendre c'est très bien et c'est un
atout pour françois fillon simplement
j'appelle ici et là se dénote non pas à
dépasser la diversité mais la diversité
n'a de sens que si elle est orientée
vers un projet collectif et vers la
victoire pas pour nous pas pour le parti
mes chers amis mais pour la france ait
l'idée qu'on s'en fait qu est une idée
trop haute alors je vous le dis autour
de françois fillon
avec françois fillon c'est ce chemin de
vérité qui va nous permettre de faire se
lever une nouvelle espérance française
partout en france c'est grâce à ce
chemin de vérité que nous allons enfin
pouvoir relever les deux grands défis
le défi du déclassement économies pour
que chaque français vivent des fruits de
leur travail pour que chaque famille
française puisse espérer pour ses
propres enfants
un sort meilleur et puis en même temps
la dépossession culturelle identitaire
si nous voulons demain faire des
réformes il faut que les français
redevienne un peuple
au delà d'une juxtaposition d'individus
d'un archipel de communauté et ils
redeviendront un peuple
animé d'une volonté collective
si on ne leur dit pas que notre projet
pour la france ça n'est que la france
devienne un carrefour anonyme du village
global ça se sent les socialistes et
monsieur vaqueront évidemment les
français veulent que l'on garantisse que
la france restera une nation une grande
nation avec des droits des droits pour
le peuple français
le premier de ces droits c'est le droit
à la continuité historique l'autre droit
c'est ce droit à se définir dans sa
propre identité et c'est une évidence
ceux qui viennent chez nous doivent
s'adapter à notre mode de vie à nos lois
il faudra toujours resté implacable
évidemment
mes chers amis c'est avec et autour de
françois que nous allons nous rassembler
pour la mère des grandes batailles la
présidentielle autour de françois nous
allons porter ce message le message d'un
peuple libre d'un peuple fier d'un
peuple souverain
avec sa force d'âme cette force d'âme
qui lui a permis aux moments les plus
tragiques de son histoire
quand la france dégringolait de relever
le drapeau français de relever cette
fierté française de dire non à tout ce
qu'ils voulaient capituler de dire non à
tout ce qu'ils voulaient reculer et bien
avec françois nous ne reculerons pas
nous ne capitulerons pas parce que vous
portez dans chacun de vos coeurs de
français
cette espérance française vous êtes mes
chers amis les sentinelles d'un combat
qui a commencé qui est le combat pour la
france pour l'espérance française alors
autour de françois fillon
nous nous rassemblant aujourd'hui et
demain vive la république française
et vive la france
[Applaudissements]